for all that's ever been said about
climate change we haven't heard nearly
enough about the psychological impacts
of living in a warming world if you've
heard the grim climate research that
science communicators like me weave into
our books and documentaries you've
probably felt bouts of fear fatalism or
hopelessness if you've been impacted by
climate disaster these feelings can set
in much deeper leading to Shock Trauma
strained relationships substance abuse
and the loss of personal identity and
control vital political and
technological work is underway to
moderate our climate chaos but I'm here
to evoke a feeling and you for why we
also need our actions and policies to
reflect an understanding of how our
changing environments threaten our
mental social and spiritual well-being
the anxiety grief and depression of
climate scientists and activists have
been reported on for years trends are
seen after extreme weather events like
hurricane sandy or Katrina for increased
PTSD and suicidality and there are rich
mental health data from northern
communities where warming is the fastest
like the Inuit and Labrador who face
existential distress as they witness the
ice a big part of their identity
vanishing before their eyes now if that
weren't enough the American
Psychological Association says that our
psychological responses to climate
change like conflict avoidance
helplessness and resignation are growing
this means that our conscious and
unconscious mental processes are holding
us back from identifying the causes of
the problem for what they are working on
solutions and fostering our own
psychological resilience but we need all
those things to take on what we've
created lately I've been studying a
phenomenon that's just one example of
the emotional hardships that we're
seeing and it comes in the form of a
question that a significant amount of
people in my generation are struggling
to answer that beam should I have a
child in the age of climate change after
all any child born today will have to
live in a world where hurricanes
flooding wildfires what we used to call
natural disasters have become
commonplace the hottest 20 years on
record occurred within
last 22 the un expects that two-thirds
of the global population may face water
shortages only six years from now the
World Bank predicts it by 2050 there's
going to be a hundred and forty million
climate refugees in sub-saharan Africa
Latin America and South Asia and other
estimates put that number at over 1
billion mass migrations of resource
scarcity increased the risk for violence
war and political instability the UN
just reported that we are pushing up to
a million species to extinction many
within decades and our emissions are
still increasing even after the Paris
agreement over the last year and a half
I've been conducting workshops and
interviews with hundreds of people about
parenting and the climate crisis and I
can tell you that people who are worried
about having kids because of climate
change are not motivated by an aesthetic
pride they're nerve-racked there's even
a movement called Birth strike whose
members have declared that they're not
going to have kids because of the state
of the ecological crisis and inaction
from governments to address this
existential threat and yes other
generations have also faced their own
apocalyptic dangers but that is no
reason to disregard the very real threat
to our survival now some feel that it's
better to adopt children or that it's
unethical to have more than one
especially three four or more because
kids increased greenhouse gas emissions
now it is a really unfortunate state of
affairs when people who want kids
sacrifice the right to because somehow
they have been told that their lifestyle
choices are to blame when the fault is
far more systemic but let's just unpack
the logic here so an off cited study
shows that on average having one less
child in an industrialized nation can
save about 59 cottons of carbon dioxide
per year while in comparison living
car-free saves nearly two and a half
tons avoiding a transatlantic flight and
this is just one saves about one and a
half tons and eating a plant-based diet
can save almost 1 ton per year and
consider that a Bangladeshi child only
adds 56 metric tons of carbon to their
parents carbon legacy over their
lifetime while an American child in
comparison adds 9000 441 to this so this
is why
some people argue that its parents from
nations with huge carbon footprints who
should think the hardest about how many
kids they have but the decision to have
a child in one's feelings about the
future are deeply personal and wrapped
up in all sorts of cultural norms
religious beliefs socioeconomic status
education levels and more and so to sum
this debate about kids in the climate
crisis can seem like it came from
another planet
many have more immediate threats to
their survival to think about like how
they're gonna put food on the table when
they're a single mom working three jobs
or they're HIV positive or they're on
the move and a migrant caravan
tragically though climate change is
really great at intersectionality it
multiplies the stresses that
marginalized communities already face a
political scientist once said to me that
a leading indicator that climate change
is starting to hit home psychologically
would be an increase in the rate of
informed women deciding to not have
children interesting is it hitting on
with you psychologically are you perhaps
someone with climate linked pre
traumatic stress a climate psychiatrist
coined that term and that's a profession
that by the way shrinks for climate woes
they're getting work at a time when some
high schoolers don't want to apply to
university any longer because they can't
foresee a future for themselves and this
brings me back to my main point the
growing concern about having kids in the
climate crisis is an urgent indicator of
how hard-pressed people are feeling
right now students around the world are
screaming for change in the piercing
voice of despair and the fact that we
can see how we contribute to this
problem that makes us feel unsafe is
crazy-making in itself climate change is
all-encompassing and so are the ways
that it messes with our minds many
activists will tell you that the best
antidote to grief is activism and some
psychologists will tell you the answer
can be found in therapy others believe
the key is to imagine you're on your
deathbed reflecting back on what's
mattered the most in your life so you
can identify what you should do more of
now at the time that you have left we
need all these ideas and more to take
care of our innermost selves as the
environments we've known become more
punishing towards us and whether you
have children or
not we need to be honest about what is
happening and what we owe one another we
cannot afford to treat the psychological
impacts of climate change is some
afterthought because the other issues of
Science and Technology and the politics
and economy feel hard while this somehow
feels soft mental health needs to be an
integral part of any climate change
survival strategy requiring funding and
ethics of equity and care and widespread
awareness because even if you're the
most emotionally avoidant person on the
planet
there's no rug in the world that's big
enough to sweep this up under thank you
[Applause]